2024 what are some of your thinking for
Content creators and maybe first for the
upstart because you're at I mean we're
at a different scale you're at a whole
different scale and some people are
trying to figure out a side hustle speak
to them and then we'll talk about media
companies at scale got it so somebody
that's getting started look at everybody
on the marketplace and S give everybody
a score here's what I mean by it so you
know how in baseball this guy Nam uh uh
Billy Bean uh the movie Moneyball with
pit right the guy Billy Bean is's the
only guy I brought to events three times
I love interviewing this guy and he
never lets me interview him it's the
only thing we love doing it but he never
wants the stuff to be recorded for
whatever reason no problem I respect it
so in baseball they say this guy's a
five tool player he's fast he's a good
hitter he's a good Defender B so he's a
five tool player right in content
creation there is the concept of five
tool except maybe it's not five tool
it's three tool it's four tool but
there's different tools so for example
in podcasting there are guys that are
very good interviewers they ask very
good questions okay there are guys that
only ask the questions that chat gbt
pops out but they don't realize as a
great interviewer ask the follow-up
question so not the first question but
the second one how did you feel about
the what do you think about this what
about if this happens what about if that
happens Chad GPT doesn't tell you the
reaction questions right but some people
are very good interviewers number
two some people are entertaining they're
funny they're comedian or they got this
temper or they got an animated way of
explaining whatever they're so the
personality is you're just attracted by
these guys like w that gu a very
interesting guy I want to know more
about the guy then the third factor of
somebody that's doing interviews is good
questions entertaining the next one is
you're sexy you're attractive you got
muscles you got nice body you got all
this sub if you got it use it right
good-looking people on camera it helps
you as well there's a lot of people that
got millions of followers because
they're attractive but nobody cares
about the content you're just hot as
hell right so then the last one is
somebody that is also very very good
with their opinions so I want to know
what does this guy think interesting
very interesting angle so for example
Joe Rogan you watch him he's
entertaining he's funny you like his
personality he can talk content on
different levels so you follow the guy
like I actually really want to hear what
this guy to say so your opinion could be
sports like all of a sudden Pat McAfee
is doing sports and talking about what's
going on and you know Aaron Rogers is on
his podcast every week and the next
thing you know Spotify picks him up and
then boom ESPN picks him up and he's
getting paid all this money what
happened all of a sudden the guy had a
personality he was different he was
fired up he's got big personality he's
asking the tough questions he's got
strong opinions criticism of the league
he's got all of that stuff he's like a
five tool content creator right so you
have to look at as a starter what angle
you going to take that's different than
others and on the content side write
down topics you're very good at and I
see how many layers you can go deep on
so for example I used to ask myself okay
let me see if I'm good into business
topics then I would watch a podcast guy
on business and he's interviewing
somebody and he asked him the question I
would say pause how would you answer it
I would answer it this way write it down
okay now let's see how he answers it
okay I think your answer is better Okay
cool so you can hang with this guy next
question boom how would you answer pause
here's how I would answer it click now
his answer is better you're kind of
checking to see what level of expertise
you got on topics so then you realize I
can't go that deep on this topic but I
can go deep on these two topics and the
market the more multi-dimensional you
are to go seven eight nine layers deeper
the more of an audience you're going to
have so some audience for vam they'll
come and say man I want lot your mob
interviews okay hey I love your business
content now I started being an
entrepreneur ever since I watched value
tment I love your political stuff I love
the podcast opinions you got on what's
going on I like your take on business I
like what you're doing with Iran I like
your interviews of
bodybuilding if you are wider with areas
you can go deeper on there's a market
for it so if you're small getting
started kind of look where you are
yourself ask others what your topics are
and then find a way to see where you're
a differentiator at and then go test it
you're never going to know what's going
to happen but you go test it and then
you're like you know what 2 years later
I only had 1,000 subscribers most people
don't realize
I did this for 2 years after you started
value tment years later two years later
only a th go look at the numbers I
started November of 2012 first video two
years later November 2014 we only have a
th000 subscribers when life of an
entrepreneur came out in 19 92s that
video was uploaded October 30th I'll
give you the exact date of 2015 if you
go look at the channel October 30th of
2015 I've already been there for 3 years
we only have 2,000 subscribers the video
goes out I put the title best
motivational video of the year it only
gets 2500 views I put it on Facebook
direct upload when Facebook first came
out with this it gets 10 million views
the first 24 hours that goes viral and
then we went to 15,000 subscribers
20,000 then I interviewed Mark Cuban
then this thing goes to 100,000 so you
can't be sitting there saying wow look
Shan's got you know this many millions
or these guys are doing this that guy's
doing that at a th000 Subs after two
years okay so you can't go doing this
expecting you're going a million within
a year so now let's talk about media
companies maybe people got money maybe
yep um if you got money do you go big
first or do you still kind of bootstrap
no there's a lot of guys that went to
spend a quar million dollars a month
buying subscribers you know who they are
I know who they are how are they doing
today Gone Gone you know why because
those subscribers bought you because you
were spending money but you're no longer
interesting you were just in their faces
so if you are able to get subscribers
without doing any ads and they show up
because your content is that great where
people are sharing it now you have real
fans that are staying with you don't get
me wrong like for us if I we spend money
on ads we're only doing ads because it's
vaal conference or BPW or we have SLS
coming up or we're doing an ad for our
app that we just launched man m i NN
eect man you can ask me any questions DM
me a text or video or I have a 50-minute
call with me and you pay for it by the
minute we'll do ads on that but we don't
do ads on YouTube channels okay we don't
do ads on that we may do in the future
but we haven't done it right now because
first go on the right see if you're
interesting see people like you see if
you're doing good then you're like okay
so some guys why I got 200,000
subscribers and I'll go and say yeah but
I look at your last 30 videos 293 views
998 views dude Peep and then I go all
the way to the back oh he has that one
video at 48 million views oh it was an
ad to a funnel I got you that's not real
250,000 Subs it's a different 250,000
Subs so if you're solving for a funnel
to sell a project product great but if
you're doing it because you want to be
an
influencer you have to go through the
grind of whether you can make it or Not
by the way you and I did it without AI
we didn't have ai we didn't have Chad
GPT we didn't have any of that stuff
you're just kind of testing today people
can do it 10 times faster than you and I
because they have better tools than we
had we didn't have these tools these
tools are making things very easy today
but the edge that we had is the audience
we got are actually audience we worked
very very hard for so that's the only
disadvantaged guys that come in with
money and they're thinking they're
winning but it's it's fake you're not
you're not really winning if you enjoy
this podcast and are ready for some deep
dive YouTube strategy just go to thanm
masterclass.com to get access to my
1hour on demand YouTube strategy class
you'll be looking over my shoulder as I
share my best tips and you can watch it
on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com